but we agree right okay that you have to
go by principles just not what you feel
right you can't I feel the ten
commandments is the truth but that's the
principle is that okay so I'm just
asking this because last week we did a
new rule about this guy this guy who was
dressed up as a Nazi in Seattle and he
may really be a Nazi or he may be just a
crazy person and maybe there's not a big
difference yeah but you know when people
saw him there on the bus it went around
the internet and some Good Samaritan
according to some people went out and
punched him out and it got a lot of
raves by liberals and liberals should
not be raving about this I mean we have
a First Amendment I don't like Nazis
either I rooted against them on Hogan's
Heroes but we have to go by principles
and not feelings that's what the other
side does you can't just punch the First
Amendment says the government can't pass
laws that abridge free speech I mean I
grew up in the home with an anti-fascist
he was my uncle who was a World War two
veteran who fought against fascism and
if he was riding that bus and saw a Nazi
symbol of someone who wanted to throw
all Jews into ovens and ethnically
cleanse all colored people from the
planet by ninety or uncle if it was
alive would have punch that son of a
in the face not a head is back
[Applause]
jews in the ovens violence an insignia
that breeds hate and it's talking about
that but it's absorb runs him in the
face no I don't believe in violence I
don't believe in violence but there
needs to be something something this man
should have and we don't believe in the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court said
they could marsh in Sochi right and we
just saw that they were able they were
allowed to march I mean this is what the
First Amendment says even if something
is odious this is America you are
allowed to eat if you throw that if you
throw the principle out the window and
just say it's how I feel then you're
just
I'm not difficult just because I want
Nazis to be punched it's not making as
bad as people who wanted three
confronted by better speech and more
speech that ain't got a principle here
the notion is I think that obviously if
someone is about to do violence if
someone shows up with a torch or with a
club and is threatening someone punching
that core punching that person is active
but we should be you should be allowed
again according to bill's principles the
First Amendment the Constitution all the
things we believe you should be able out
to speak without being punched in the
face it's all Beach or sit on a bus so
we should be able to say we don't hate
Nazis we have Nazism we hate fascism
were against it it's also saying we
don't like violence there's this dog
whistle that's been going around the
nation and people are listening to the
call and the problem is some of these
old laws need to be revisited because
they just don't fit some of what's going
on and the bottom line he has freedom of
speech but yes he was intimidating and
citing and that is not right and also
this is what bothers me about liberals
there are no Nazi throwing jews in the
ovens now in America this thing about
but you know doing something that looks
like it takes courage and it does not
first of all I'm not a liberal okay so
but the difference between
Charlottesville and Boston was very very
clear the odds were even in
Charlottesville and that's when someone
got killed when teacher Tory torches in
the streets in in Boston the Nazis were
outnumbered 20 to 1 they hid in the
little cabana Coppola place scared to
death and asked for the police to take
them out there because of the because
people stood up and said we're not going
to under any circumstances allow this
ideology to be one that has reign in the
United States but they did it but they
did it in a peaceful and nonviolent way
in Boston very very effectively anybody
they felt they that was safe thoughts
what they did they felt comfortable
marching without hoods there because
they are now without hoods in the Oval
Office and that's where it's Terry
Belafonte six
harry bellafonte said something for me
before harry belafonte said you know
when he walked with dr. king and w eb de
bois
he said when there's great pain there is
a time for activism and that activism
creates change and we see it at these
little moments but there needs to be
some kind of galvanizing and coming
together because it should not be that
people walk down the street about about
whether it's Nazism or whether it's
about the Confederate statues this has
got to stop because there is a bubbling
up in this nation right now when it
comes it's race was alive with with
Harry Belafonte two years ago really yes
he won't you walked with him and talked
with him Paul Robeson and dr. King
Frederick Douglass